okay we are now live on YouTube
and please proceed
Thank You Pam
I'd like to welcome everyone today
today's work session on the executive
departments and administration committee
this will be the first live-streaming
work session on legislation
as chair of the executive departments
and Administration Committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the Cova
19 pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020 - hold
for this public body is authorized to
meet electronically please note there is
no physical location to observe and
listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order and
confirming that we are a
providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means we are utilizing zoom
for this electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by clicking on the following website
address
HTTP colon 4 / 4 / zoom dot u.s.
/j 4/9 six to seven zero four seven nine
one eight three or dialing one of the
following phone numbers 1 9 - 9 - 0 5 6
0 9 9 or 1 301 seven one five eight five
nine to be providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting we previously gave notice to
the public of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
C providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting if there are problems with
access if anybody has a problem please
call six zero three two seven one three
six zero zero or email at HC s @ l EG
dot state dot NH dot u s d returning the
meeting if the public is unable to
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I
want to introduce the staff that are on
the meeting assisting us p.m. smiling
senior House committee researcher is the
meaning host additional host community
services that providing support of Brad
Greenland Gen 4 and Kristina Dyer this
is a work session for House bill 1692
and House bill 1710 these bills were
referred to the EDA committee as a
second committee pursuant to house rule
46 F I have waived the public hearings
on these bills copies of the bills an
amendment to HB 1692 and other relevant
materials have been posted on the main
page of the General Court website under
the heading remote meetings
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call vote and let's start this
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
KT and when each member states their
presence is also state whether they are
is anyone in the room with energy during
the meeting which is acquired under the
right to know law
case received a text from crew states
that she left her computer hook up and
went to phone but even as an attendee
not as a panelist
so Jen are you getting represent of
shots
what is her first name christina is
phone number four three eight zero
two seven five two two two seven
the pink I
only know her landline number eight five
six seven two seven nine oh okay it's
one of those two yeah I just wanted Oh
is she in I
thought on the list LG
she went off her computer connection
because it was too salty and so she just
texted me that she called him but it's
showing her as an attendee or announced
that she was as an attendee not a
panelist
I don't her and she disappeared
representative Judy just popped up in
the attendee list as well if we could
move him up
I've got another text from Chris Schulz
she said she's going back in a zoom
that's you bless you who has the virus
here
is the panel called Jackie has the virus
most likely allergy
what they all say
okay has anybody spotted representative
he's back in yes
she's me oh there you are I'm sorry
and we just need represent a Judy moved
up on
the screen we can't move him out of the
attendee list but he can speak
okay he looks like he's in he's a
panelist he does show up on our panel
but on the listing he shows under
attendees
I'm gonna ask
representative
here is the role representative show it
here is my cat
meow
representative Joo Dee yes we that means
oh
are you alone or was anyone with you
I'm in my office my wife hey she's in
the house
representative Schmidt
representative Schmidt going once
represent his fear I'm here can you hear
me yes I did I can't weaken yeah I'm
here I'm at a friend's house she is
currently in the room
okay representative Schultz
representative Schultz are you out there
I am but it's still lagging at time so I
apologize I am at home and my husband
will be in and out of the room
okay well put down an in-and-out X
representative Fontenot
where did you go
representative fun no he was here a
while ago he's not muted but he's also
not being heard
but yes yes now we hear you
with
home alone
representative to then
present
and
present and alone representative fellows
present alone
representative Fox
present home with my three year old
representative grow to
present home alone
representative merchant present home my
wife will be in and out
representative Pimentel
present home other people in the house
but they shouldn't be disturbed
representative McGuire
present how my husband may be in and out
the clerk is home alone
representative Boden's dozen and home
alone
representative Prue
at the EPI pink fire department in the
small OC and I am alone at this moment
in time
representative kind of City I am home in
Amherst New Hampshire my wife is in the
house somewhere
representative Pierson is
not present is that correct no word
that's correct he's not present
representative Jakob ovitch present home
alone in the room
representative McDonald
present along in an office
representative goli
present with my wife in and out at times
okay
well if it were poker would be pretty
close to a full house for short one
let the roll being taken I will open the
meeting with public hearing the work
session I shall say
and we will start with
Hospital 1692 and
I have brought forward an amendment that
I think everybody has in front of them
and
we have a minute to get that in front of
you and then I will discuss what this
amendment does
it's fairly straightforward
it is amendment 2 0 2 0 - 1 2 4 3 h
and the first thing it does is it
corrects the first part of the amendment
lines 1 through
pretty much most of it redefines what
had happened was
it was a drafting error in OLS
143 - a : 25 was put in there twice
and we all know that he can't have the
same citation in statute twice with
different meanings so it corrected that
and it made a 25 to 26 and a 27 so
that's all that corrected in the
amendment
and the other part was
if I man just the other part of the
amendment
Rick Lee takes out the definition
removes the definition of commodity in
the partner rule so wild harvested
mushrooms this was at the request of the
department in the sponsor response I had
this amendment usually drafted most of
us had it had it in front of us and when
this went out to be put in my name
because OLS said we could not accept any
other members amendment it had to be
from a committee member so that's why I
had that drafted and when drafting it
they noticed the other drafting error
that fixed it fix the problem
so if there are any questions on the
amendment you could raise your hand and
then once we get done the amendment I
will recognize representative fellows
who sat on the Commission to give an
update as to what was that
mr. chairman representative Hanna city
has his hand up
mr. Chairman I don't have a copy of the
amendment
everyone should have had a copy in a
packet that Pam sent out there was a
whole packet on
research on all the bills we had before
us as well as I've not received a packet
I'm representative Penna city all all
the information that was sent out to
committee members was also posted on the
general court website under the remote
meetings link on that main page that
might be the easiest way to access it
right now
what is it it on the if you go to the
main page of the General Court website
yep and then you see there's a box on
the sort of mid right-hand side that
says remote meetings and there's the e
DNA meeting link
you see that new
word session mm-hmm right yeah you click
on that you'll see a whole list of
copies of the bills and the amendment
got it now thank you all right goody
any other questions on the amendment
before I turn it over to represent
fellows
seeing none represent fellows who are
recognized this one's on you but you may
speak
thank you
I just wanted to say that I served on
the study Commission for this bill and
this is bill that we heard last year
it's just to make to form the study
committee and I served on a study
committee and I think there's a very
strong support from all quarters for the
concept to license wild mushroom
harvesters it would be good for the food
industry and it also protects the
citizens because they will be given
guarantees so that the mushrooms that
they buy either through a restaurant or
at a farm stand are safe
this bill was amended by the Agriculture
and Environment Committee and
they shift one of the things that they
did is from the original bill to this
version they shifted responsibility some
of the responsibilities from the
Department of Agriculture to the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I think that in I have some concerns
I think in a normal situation this bill
would be great to just go to the Senate
the fiscal note says that the costs are
indeterminable and this doesn't have an
opportunity to go to house finance
because we are the second committee but
I have concerns that the
the cost and the staffing that would be
required to implement this by Health and
Human Services has not been addressed
some of the costs are not identified in
the fiscal note in the fiscal note
interment also determines that the cost
they did it and to play have an
indeterminable
cost and impact on the department
thank you
next I am going to
recognize
Colleen Smith if she can address the
cost items okay if you could unmute her
if she's here he is here she is
and also representative Connor has his
hand up now
Colleen's hand is up and Colleen is here
with us Colleen you recognized to
address those questions and concerns
good morning my name is Colleen Smith
I'm an administrator for the food
protection section within the Department
of Health and Human Services
I served also on the same Commission
that representative fellows did we you
know certainly tried to model the this
program similar to a program that we
have for rabbit and poultry producers
and
also
acknowledged that there were some there
was some startup work we collaborated
with Department of Agriculture and UNH
Cooperative Extension and to develop a
curriculum and a program this it's a
similar model with this mushroom wild
mushroom program in that we would also
collaborate again with the UNH Extension
and with Department of Agriculture so
certainly there are some start there's
some start up work meetings discussion
but that is that's why we had outline
this is indeterminable cost the program
was to be the curriculum is to be
administered by UNH UNH extension or a
similar
University that has that capability
should UNH not be able to move forward
with this in the future
that was the model that we had based on
again very similar to a program that we
had it collaborated with those two
entities a few years ago so we're not
expecting that there would be
you know certainly a need for a position
dedicated to this that this could be
absorbed within the course of our
regular work there are some licensing
costs that are built in you know
certainly we would go through rulemaking
process to set those and again we
because this is a new program it's it's
hard to say how many
how many the actual licensees we would
have we estimated I think I believe 30
over the course of the first few years
that would take advantage of this
certainly happy to answer any other
questions that you have I
see represented McGuire has a hand of
represent of wire Thank You mr. chair I
have a couple of questions the first is
did the committee find any actual cases
of poisoning but by wild mushrooms in
the state
where does that fellows the money is
that
I
don't recall any discussion about that
happening within the state but it
definitely has happened in other parts
of the country
and in the
approach of the committee is to have two
tiers of mushrooms in Tier one mushrooms
are those that are easily
distinguished would be poisonous and
be licensed to harvest those mushrooms
there's a second tier when where
somebody would need and a lot of
experience to be able to distinguish the
ones that are dangerous so our objective
is to make sure that that there is no
poisoning we would have to try to
contact the poison Bureau you know to to
determine exactly how often that happens
you're muted
can we get
yes thank you
the my concern is that the we're
creating a lot of work for a problem
that doesn't exist in the state but
we'll discuss that later my other
question is that this talks about
requiring mushrooms from out of state to
be from people suitably licensed by the
other states
miss Pam do we know what our adjacent
states do about mushroom gatherers
because that is obviously going to be an
issue and
Canada -
um
the committee certainly looked at other
states regulating I don't have that
information in front of me I don't know
if representative fellows or
representative Kirk have as many fellows
has your hand up and
so I can I can tell you some of that we
know that in in Maine they several years
ago they passed a bill
providing that mushroom harvesters can
be licensed but they never implemented
it because they ran into some
issues
which I can't remember offhand I can't
remember what those issues were and the
committee also talked to someone from
Rhode Island and
they are
licensing some people but they don't
really have a formal process like we're
talking about now they just kind of take
it on a one at a time basis and I can't
tell you
Massachusetts in Vermont I I think
probably they just don't because I think
we would have discussed it if they did
that's the scope of what I can share
Thank You Pam can we get I know
represent connect us and further info on
that
sure
representative connect you should be
able to speak you're all set up now
he's now he now you're ready okay yes
well let me first of all if I missed
something when represent a fellow's was
speaking of us because I was checking in
that amendment but I hope I'm not being
redundant the most important issue that
understand is the 2017 us food code
states that unless a food service in an
order for a food service establishment
to serve or sell wild harvested
mushrooms in the US they have to be
approved to do so by a regulatory
authority worth jurisdiction over the
food establishment so this would be any
restaurants any grocery stores farmers
markets all those things and that
approval requires the proper
identification of the wild mushrooms
being sold or served so the point is
without this program the the restaurants
who are currently serving wild mushrooms
that have been sold to them or grocery
stores will not be allowed to do that
anymore currently if an inspector goes
in and they see a wild mushroom which is
not
identified as a as approved it has to be
pulled and thrown away so this is
actually just to allow us to be in
compliance with the US Food Code for our
restaurants and grocery stores farm
stands and farmers markets to sell or
serve wild harvested mushrooms and
that's really the major Reese why it
needs to be put in place with response
to the issue of poisoning it isn't
always even just an issue of a person
getting markedly sick and dying with
renal failure a padi failure or whatever
there are also mushrooms that are just
simply not very edible and the the must
early I should say that the restaurant
would not really like it if they
purchased some mushrooms they thought
were fine they served them and they were
just tough chewy and edible and also
other times they caused just a mild
degree of illness gastrointestinal
illness it's not reported to a poison
center and some of these that have a
high incidence today I will go on that
your to list the representative fellows
discussed but the issue is to make sure
that when somebody goes in to sell to a
restaurant or to a grocery store a store
or to a farmers market if they're
selling at the farmers market that what
they're selling is actually what is safe
to sell and that they know what they're
doing
thank you thank you and represent if can
arc one quick question for you yes sir
the reason why we have to use the why we
have to do this because of in the FDA
code is because Health and Human
Services has adopted that code is that
correct yes yes exactly the the point is
the US Food Code is there and the the
the our food protection service is
adopted they rules for that and that I
have a copy of the actual
rule and that it was sent to you by
email I sent out an email to everybody
back a week or so ago summarizing all
this and again it's definitely says
mushroom species picked in the wild
shall not be offered for sale or service
by a food establishment unless the food
establishment has been approved to do so
and it does not apply to processed
mushrooms or cultivated mushrooms that
are inspected it just has to do with the
gathering of wild thank you
any other comments or questions
represented merchants has his hand up
where is our merchant
Thank You mr. chair
what I'm looking through the bill and
also to the amendment I don't see really
a definition of a wild mushroom and what
I'm concerned about is that the species
may be grown in the wild as well as
cultivated so therefore if we how do we
categorize something so someone
understands that if it's grown in the
wild it's wild regardless of the species
if it's cultivated it's cultivated
regardless of the species
is there any comment about that is my
concern I
think represented cannot just read the
definition and it was clearly stated in
the FDA code that cultivator is not
included
if we could maybe unmute calling Smith
and she may have also have a better
answer yes Carlina is available
yes yes that is Curtis correct as
representative Konerko stated in the
definition of the code is that
cultivated mushrooms would not be
included as a wild mushroom these are
these are meant to cover eye mushrooms
that would be foraged in the wild not
through a controlled environment as
cultivated mushrooms would be
thank you
Judy is in the attendee lesson has his
hand up
thank you thank you mr. chair I have a
same concern like whip is that is not my
gear
as all of you knows I come from an
island Haiti and
for the wild mushroom in Haiti
we we don't eat those mushrooms because
they are poisoning so I would like to
know if there is a study about it in
your MSHA before we put them out
put them out for sale
cannot you just want to explain the tier
1 and tier 2 to represented Julian now
they would be identified but yes may I
can you hear me now yes yes ok basically
we we had on our Commission I chaired
that Commission and we had on that
Commission dr. Rick van de Paul who is
the head of the Ring of mycology
Association and we also had another
active forager and we also had testimony
from other foragers we developed a list
together as we work through we actually
had a very long and large list we kept
whittling it down to try to make it a
little bit more manageable in any case
uh the data about these is constantly
changing and that's why in the bill it
doesn't list these other mushrooms if
you know and from time it from here on
it states that a list will be maintained
because that list will need to be
updated on occasion when new information
comes in about a mushroom which might
have a toxicity or
sometimes mushrooms have name changes
and that would need to be changed as
well so that will be a living document
that will be maintained by the
Department of Health and Human Services
and that would be allowed to be we would
be actually
updating that and that kind of
information is sent out to the food
establishments as well so they know but
in any case we do have a good wealth of
information about toxicity of arras
mushrooms but as anything else in
medicine as we learn new things we have
to update the data that we have and this
would be updated to represent that does
that answer your question I hope
thank you yes thank you visit a few
thank you thank you any other questions
or comments
Smit with his hand up
Schmidt
Thank You mr. chairman I'm glad we're
having this discussion because I think
it's very important for people to
understand that
food safety is not some kind of a mild
concern we already have enough problems
with you know improperly and hygienic
the produced meats that have poisoning
in several instances in our recent
history killed people and some of the
flesh rumors some of the wild mushrooms
even having their name
there's a word deadly how anita comes to
Maya and it's called deadly I'm Anita
and this is the kind of thing that the
average person knows nothing about so
having these licensed certified
harvesters and so forth it is in the
public interest and
I'm going to be strongly supportive of
the amendment and the bill
representative Bowden has a hand up and
if I just may remind people this is a
work session not an exact session to be
making comments on how they're going to
vote on this bill yet we're not there
thank you represent a boat Thank You mr.
chair I noticed in the bill that we are
granting DHHS the authority to issue to
create a fine schedule for violations of
the subdivision in my eight years in the
legislature this is the first time I've
ever seen or haven't noticed at least
whereas we've granted the state agency
the authority to create a fine schedule
I think it's that we should in the least
specify what the fine schedule is in
this bill before it's moved on to an
executive session Thank You Pam correct
me if I'm wrong this is done in other
agencies as well correct well this isn't
the first time we've done something like
this for an agency that's true you know
there's as with you know a number of
laws and little uniformity sometimes the
fees are set in sections sometimes
they're not correct thank you sure and
representative McGuire has her hand up
McGuire Thank You mr. chair
so I am I didn't get representative
Kirk's email about the
adopting the federal code for foods and
I think that's necessary
represent Koerner can we get you to send
that back out uh yes I can do that
within just a moment I can also simply
read it to you if you wish or better yet
Coleen Smith is still on the call likely
and she would be the expert on then who
reported this to our Commission
miss Matthew just want to address how
healthy Human Services deals with the
food code
so we have adopted the 2017 version of
the food code that's the latest model
code for the regulation of food
establishments so that version was
adopted into our administrative rules
through gel car approval back in August
of 2019 so previous to that we were on
the 2009 code which also did address
wild mushrooms and at that time we had
we had taken at that time that code had
said there needed to be a wild mushroom
expert in the state and so we had not we
had not allowed wild mushrooms
altogether because we had no wild
mushroom expert in the state the 2017
code allows for the state to come up
with its own certification program and
that's certainly the model that we
followed through this out the study
commissioned in which we proposed here
too and it very much aligns with the
2017 FDA code which are which is part of
our administrative rules
and if a restaurant wanted to
serve wild mushrooms currently
would they be able to I know a lot of
restaurants around are going to the
farm-to-table are trying to use local
resources for their products and what
they serve currently are they allowed
you
so currently there's no approval process
in the state for them so as was
mentioned previously if an inspector
visited that restaurant that had that
was choosing to offer a wild mushrooms
we wouldn't consider them an approved
source unless they were buying them from
a purveyor that had
received them from a certified source
from another state or another country
but currently New Hampshire doesn't have
an approval process for wild mushrooms
so if they were deemed to be obtained
from a New Hampshire source
they would not be allowed
so that's probably the reason why we're
hearing from some of these restaurants
that they want this going forward
exactly and as was mentioned before is
is it certainly is this program would
provide an assurance program assurance
to the restaurant that they were getting
a product from someone deemed an expert
and you know they wouldn't be passing on
some subsequent risk to their patrons of
having a misidentified mushroom that
could cause illness thank you
and further questions representative
fellowes has her hand up
represented fellows thank you just as a
follow-up to two of the earlier comments
on the first page of the bill on line 16
there's an identification of the tier 1
mushrooms and those are only mushrooms
that are easily identified and have no
look-alikes and so the committee won't
as we discuss this we discussed the
mushrooms we thought would likely be put
on this list and there's only about 10
of them and they're really I can assure
you that there's no danger in any of
those mushrooms and in terms of the
restaurants being able to know what it
is that they're buying part of the bill
I'm not sure which section it is but it
requires Health and Human Services to
provide information to the restaurants
or
establishments and with pictures so that
you could be able to identify the
mushrooms that that come to them by a
harvester and the third thing I'd like
to do is just to get absolutely
clarity from Colleen Smith about the
ability of the department to
implement the provisions of this statute
by the deadline which is
effective date is January 1st
21 given the situation we're in right
now are you still confident that the
Department will be able to do that thank
you
Miss Smith
am I am i unmuted yes perfect Thanks so
I I certainly
as as things have evolved over the last
few months this would definitely be a
challenge and you know certainly we are
relying again collaboratively to work
with UNH and also agriculture on
developing this curriculum there that
depending on when this bill ultimately
would get passed into law it there might
be some challenges with meeting that
January 1st deadline I would if we could
have at least another six months I would
say that given the the current state and
other issues that we are dealing with
right now it would give us definitely
some a little bit more flexibility and
and also giving us time to do due
diligence and in working with those
other agencies to come up with a program
I think
just answered the question but to
calling Smith in the section on the
amendment duties Department of Health
and Human Services
Roman 1 and 2 paragraphs 1 & 2 mentioned
I just wanted to know if that meant
pictures
yeah idea would be yes to provide photos
okay thank you
and
representative Bowden has his hand up
represent Bowden thank you just wanna we
revisit the fine schedule and this
question is for one of the three members
of each committee if the DHA just came
back to the gel car pardon while they're
entering rulemaking and gel car felt
that they're fine schedule was excessive
with Jack I have the authority to
amend that fine schedule or does it
require legislative activities
represent McGuire
yeah muted alright I
think she seems to be frozen yes
ever they wanted there you go could you
repeat that representing acquire you
froze on us oh sorry
gel car could object if they thought it
was not in the public interest but my
feeling is it would have to be grossly
exorbitant you know a thousand dollars a
day for poor record-keeping or whatever
for us to feel that we had a
leg to stand on because this bill gives
them full authority I would say that
we're going to amend the bill anyway we
should put in a maximum fine at the very
least
and I agree with them we don't just want
to give them total authority
thank you mister chairman representative
SciTech would like to ask a question
he's not showing up on our list but I'm
going to recognize him if it's all right
represent a psychic yeah I have I have a
few things does food establishment mean
restaurant that's what that means
miss Smith's alone yes we're gonna see
if we can get an answer for you miss it
yes it does include
include restaurants retail stores anyone
offering food to the public
okay
a couple other things first I heard the
word guarantee used early in this
discussion and I think that's a little
ever stated just to keep our feet on the
ground here I the given that the F we
have a subscribed to the FDA's code
there seems to be little choice and this
work session is oozing its way into an
executive session
we really were going to talk about the
amendment but since it's turned into a
bit of a free-for-all I'm going to
mention a couple things that I didn't
that concern me technically about the
bill first is it licenses distributors
identifier and
harvesters I don't know why a
distributor has to be licensed if he's
gotten it from a licensed harvester
distributor Geiger I just don't see that
the role of an identifier is it is it's
he's licensed but I don't see that that
has any that the identifier has any part
it plays any role in the process the
harvester sells
mushrooms that is that he has passed the
tier to tier one exam for we trust that
we have a higher level of assurance the
distributor gets it I don't know what
the
identifier is going to do so my my
concerns are that this is not
technically you've done very well I
don't think there's any big harm given
30 people blah blah blah so I think the
FDA is sort of going to even though mr.
chair you don't want to hear this that
it's not an executive session what
choice do we have
anyways that's all I really wanted to
say thank you Miss Smith do you have a
response to them why the distributor
needs to be licensed
so these two are terms that were were
vetted pretty extensively in our study
commissioned work because the the idea
is that in some cases the distributor
has has
their you have nothing to do with the
downstream process yet they're the the
actual one that takes the responsibility
and providing them to to the restaurant
so they might not have been actually the
one to harvest the mushrooms or identify
the mushrooms but they're the one
they're the entity that's actually the
direct contact with the restaurant
itself
and mr. chairman just so you know
representative Connor and representative
Bixby are both in the attendee list with
their hands up but we also have
representative Pimentel next from the
committee members okay and and this I
guess one last question going to Miss
Smith would this be
requiring a distributor because
mushrooms may come from another state
that doesn't have a licensing process to
allow them to be moved on to our
restaurants
that could be an instance as well so
that was another reason to be inclusive
of both of all three identifiers as
harvesters and distributors
represent is recognized
Thank You mr. chairman just
the fact that the January first
date of implementation seems to be
problematic just
changing it to
six months or after the bill is signed
would take care of that problem
okay we'll think about it and see if we
can get it may be an amendment drafted
changing that
and any other committee members
prove with the question represent
approval so I noticed in the amendment
on line 16 it says Department do
not exceed $2 for each violation so that
there's something already in there I
know I'm a little blagging behind in
this conversation but thank you for
pointing that out yep
representative Schmidt has his hand up
we're
thank you I'd like also to speak on the
subject of represent Boden's question
members have to understand that the gel
car process is not a take-it-or-leave-it
that the public is involved as a right
to be involved in the establishment of
rules and and they do participate and
the objections that they raise if they
are not sufficiently addressed in the
process they can be raised again in the
gel car hearing which is also a public
hearing and one of the questions I
always ask if somebody in the public eye
you know appears in opposition to
something whether this was something
that was addressed by them in the you
know in that development of the rules of
process and that is something that the
gel car frequently checks to so it's not
a take-it-or-leave-it situation as one
without the necessary experience and all
this might assume from remarks that were
made previously this is an engagement
back and forth to develop the best rules
possible but the gel car is the final
say on this so I think that that we are
not inviting the the purveyors to abuse
the system by the by the amendment that
we're offering
McGuire has her hand up
Thank You mr. chair I was looking at the
food rules that represent of connect
very kindly sent me and it appears that
this bill doesn't comply with them it
requires the food establishment to be
approved it doesn't say anything about
only buying from approved suppliers
so I think that this bill is
doesn't address the issue that it's
trying to solve
I'm also concerned that it appears to be
setting up three identical licenses with
different names and
how do we know who's an identifier and
who's who's a distributor and why do we
care
Miss Smith would you like to address the
FDA rules and why this is a requirement
so
within the food the food code are the
standards for our regulation of food
establishments which include restaurants
retail stores so one of the one of one
of the elements of the food code is that
all food comes from an approved source
and the food code is is very specific to
certain commodities whether it be eggs
whether it be meat whether it be produce
what constitutes in an approved source
wild mushrooms are are very specifically
delineated as the criteria for their
approval and so to be deemed an approved
source and to be allowable to be used at
a licensed food establishment the
criteria set forth in the food code is
that the supplier be approved through
through a state program and it gives
recommendations as to the elements of
that program that the person is trained
and recognized in being able to solidly
identify mushrooms that are safe for
consumption correctly so so certainly we
we have had many
wild mushroom harvesters come to us over
the years who want to be approved to
provide their products that they harvest
to be their grocery stores or
restaurants and we simply don't have an
approval process for them so we've told
them we've told them no you know so we
did try on an ad hoc basis probably
about five years ago where we had
members from agriculture and
dr. van der polis represent of connect
had mentioned before who had a vetted
interest in trying to stand something up
in the state as as our own workgroup we
didn't have we couldn't pull it gather
because there were a lot of issues
around licensing around land landowner
trespassing and where these are
harvested it was a bigger project than
that we felt we could do without some
legislation and rulemaking to go along
with it and certainly that's what
historically prompted the the idea of
the study commission to study all the
issues around this and then the
subsequent legislation this this this
session to put that into place
so that's kind of a long answer but but
that if you know certainly happy to
respond to any follow-up questions
any other questions
thank you I just wanted to respond to an
earlier question or a clarification that
it's not the intent for there to be
three different licenses for harvesters
distributors and identifiers the intent
is to have one license the same
educational requirements for all three
of those activities would be two
different licenses but that just has to
do with if it's for the Tier one like
the ten mushrooms to identify in Tier
two which are the more complicated ones
and representative McGuire has your hand
up represent McGuire yes Thank You mr.
chair
regarding the
approval I appreciate that the
rules require an approved source for
food however the rule specifically says
mushroom species picked in the wild
shall not be offered for sale unless the
food establishment has been approved to
do so so I think we either need to
modify that or we need we we need to do
something about that because it doesn't
have an exemption for
mushrooms picked by an approved
identifier
I think if we're all I go and have one
license we shouldn't we should just say
one thing I think identifier as the
right title
but that's it that's a myth
[Music]
and
mr. chairman we've got representative
Turner who has his hand up and also
representative dick speak from the
audience
I will recognize representative Bixby
first sure
okay
Bixby hello thank you for taking my
question
so I was looking at page 1 of the bill
under penalty and
it looks like the for all the possible
violations there is a maximum of fine of
it says not to exceed 1000 and my under
protection of Hawaiian on page 2 that
gives the department rulemaking
authority is that that would be in order
to make those under 1000 dollar fines
more specific
that is correct that's as discussed
previously that is I think that so that
will be taken at the Joker will not
cheat $1,000
please
and further comment representative
Connor had his hand up before represent
Connor you're recognized thank you very
much I have I've been making a little
list to go over first let me go over
that issue about the food establishment
approval I
think what Colleen Smith was pointing
out is the food establishment gains
their approval by their proper sourcing
records that's their approval to sell a
wild mushroom is the fact that they have
a sourcing record that this came from an
approved harvester or distributor so
that they know that it is safe that's
why they have to keep that record and
that is the the whole genesis of this so
it is not really a matter of approving
them it's a matter of approving this
sources and that's what Colleen Smith
was saying if the inspector from food
protection goes there's no source record
then that is not approved they are not
approved to sell that that's how they
gain their approval sir okay
the fine schedule yes the maximum is
that really both for the person who
either to harvest identify or distribute
without a license and also for a food
establishment serving and each of those
are $1000 maximum so those are set now
the goal of this actually is for the
restaurant to not necessarily have to
actually identify they would be provided
information and pictures but they would
not have to because they would have a
reliable source who is certified to sell
it to them however that is why one of
the major reasons we allowed this
subgroup of identifier z' that's what an
identifier might be a restaurant may
have someone in their staff who is
licensed as an identifier so they can
double check the mushrooms which are
being provided to them that's a choice
that they might have
it was also stated I think fairly
clearly that the issue is some
distributors might have some harvesters
working for them who just do a very
small amount and that's why if they're
still going to be the one who sells it
they're the one who has to hold the
license
so and the last thing was the timing a
lot of the framework for the educational
course actually has already done I think
it will be appropriate to push it out to
six months after the bill is passed
because we don't know how fast thing is
going to go but the framework for the
course has already been developed
primarily by dr. van de poele and there
is an in similar
course being taught by dr. Neath is down
at UNH so we don't really have to start
from scratch on the courses they partly
exist or they just have to fine-tune how
they're going to be done thank you thank
you
any other comments or questions I don't
see any other hands up mr. chairman but
I see representative Pierson has joined
us welcome represent Pearson
all right if there's no further question
so we're going to move on to the next
bill start the work session
which is House bill 1710
[Applause]
relative disclosure of results of child
daycare monitoring visits
any questions or concerns or comments
on House bill 1710
that the committee has I
don't see any hands give a few more
minutes for folks to look over and
review I
do see a hand from child guidance out in
the attendee list if you want a food
comment I'm not going to take public
comment at this time this is some kind
of public hearing I
think this is one of the topics we've
discussed previously in some of our
hearings on
findings during
investigations and this is just moving
us a little forward in the right
direction
so if there is no other
comments
no hands in view well represent approve
I see a hand in front of the monitor
prove
muted so I guess my question is I know
we extended the day's out 15 for
them to have time to respond now if
they're asking for a hearing does that
delay the posting to their website
there's someone here from
licensing or daycares yes Melissa
Clement is out in the audience and she
has her hand up
miss Clement could you help us with that
good morning mr. chair and the committee
so the process for posting online
is separate from the process of when
they are asked for an informal dispute
resolution so if they ask for an
informal dispute resolution they have
different timelines in order to do that
there is nothing in the statute here
that discusses what happens when they
have an informal dispute resolution
versus when we post the inspections
online that's not addressing on
legislation
there would be separate legislation if
we did that correct this isn't
yes there's a separate statute regarding
the informal dispute resolution process
thank you
so I know right if there's a
complaint against them but they resolve
it doesn't get resolved but now they
want to hearing that it gets posted
until those all resolved right so until
they exhausted all measures
be posed because they could come out
that they weren't wrong but it's now
been posted that they were wrong and
were
causing them harm
this climate the rivers
yeah so the way it works now is if
someone responds and they have they wish
to dispute their findings we post that
information online as well so
we would follow the timelines a Centon
statute if we have a dispute that goes
beyond that is requested as required we
would put their dispute online as well
it would be clearly indicated that the
findings were
being disputed that's our process now
and we would continue with that process
as well
Thank You
representative Fox has a hand up
represent Fox thank you I just wanted to
comment I was on the study committee
that participated this this bill being
brought forward and
it was sorry it was a request at the
request of take care operators who have
microfauna to prove had damage done by
not having
so that kids can go to daycare
thank you
other questions representative Schmidt
has a hand up represents MIT
thank you very much mr. chair well as a
member of the jell car I certainly have
been a witness to
disputes involving daycare providers
appearing before the jello car with
concerns and I think this is one of the
issues that has been most contentious is
the idea that something that is brought
to their attention
by to the attention of the Department
they come in they investigate and so
forth and that something can be posted
before the issue is resolved and of
course this to the degree that it's a
legitimate can get amid finding and
something needs to be you know fixed or
stopped whatever the particular
violation might be or no any finding
that is potentially harmful to the to
the public and especially to young
children
but but to the degree that the
Department the scene is judge jury and
executioner as well is something that
that troubles many of us who have dealt
with this situation and and so I think
we have to I think we have to be very
mindful of the fact that that and
operations reputation is on the line
when they are accused of something
obviously for something that is clearly
a violation clearly a harmful to the
public health that the department has
authority to act in those situations act
immediately but there there are much
lesser findings in some cases which
still can be harmful to
child care entities ability to still
attract the public so I think we have to
be very careful about
allowing information to be posted until
it has been resolved along the lines of
what represented proofs at a moment ago
so I think we have to be very careful
before we allow the department to
and we have seen situations where people
were where inspectors were accused of
being heavy handed or retaliatory and so
forth and so on this is an area where we
have to be very careful that we do not
allow you know overreach to occur
where a matter has not been resolved
thank you any further questions
another Brodeur has a hand up thank you
thank you mr. chair so I've read this
bill as intent to bring more
transparency to the process
and I would like to know from the
department from the agency
the difference is between what they do
know and what's what this bill
involves
if the administrator
yes thank you well what this film will
be doing is providing additional time
for the
providers to be able to have their
findings sent to them and then reviewed
and provide their response prior to us
posting it online currently what happens
is we based on the previous statute is
we would send the providers their
findings and then within five days
business days of those findings being
sent to the program they would then be
posted online before the providers would
have to provide their corrective action
plan or give a
asked for them to be disputed because
currently they have 14 days to send us a
request to dispute the findings that
were sent to them so this process allows
the findings not to be made public
before the 15 days
and it allows them more time to provide
the corrective action plan or to dispute
so it would delay it being put on a mine
for a longer
thank you
represent Rhoda you have a follow up
she does not any other questions
or comments
we just got um look Melissa Clement has
one more thing to say this clinic or I
just wanted to make the committee aware
that there is a study committee that has
been asked for to review our informal
dispute resolution process which will be
occurring late and once the legislation
is passed this year so that whole
process will be reviewed and revised
potentially next session so this is a
post this is these statutes are with
addresses when we post information and
then we're going to be awful looking at
our whole IDR process
thank you and I believe that was House
bill 17 of 11 that we passed
representative Peru has a hand up where
was that proof so again I'm just gonna
reiterate I really don't like things
being posted until their final and I
think we should correct that and I'm
glad that you know we're doing that
committee to look at that whole process
because I keep it
fairly flawed
but I have a lot of problems with
posting people are in that process
haven't had time to resolve it and until
it's resolved it shouldn't be posted
and I agree but I think what we have
before us is better than what we have
currently and it's a move in the right
direction until we get the study
committee to do their work and come back
with further findings
further comments or questions we have
represented merchants has his hand up
okay and just a reminder we are not an
executive session if we want to dispute
or talk about why we should have another
why we shouldn't have the bill if he
could hold off at the week second this
is for questions you may have for
mr. Clement or the sponsor representing
Archer Thank You mr. chair this question
is from miss Clement I looked into the
line 9 it appears to be that any
findings by the department remain on the
website for three years going back to
represent a cruise point if something is
found to be not valid or overturned does
that mean it still stays on the website
for three years or does it come down
it comes down the minute that we the
informal dispute resolution process we
address that by we have a meeting or
they present information in writing to
us we then reevaluate the findings we
make any changes to what we call the
statement of findings which is what's
posted online and the only thing that is
public is what is then revised as a
result of that informal dispute
resolution process
any further comments or questions
before we go
no hands are raised
all right I'm going to close the work
session on these two bills and we will
move into executive session and
once again I will have to read the
script seeing where you're starting a
new meeting
and we will have to do a roll one more
time going into the executive session
for those that are with us
as chair of the house executive
departments and administration committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covert 19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020 - so for this public body is
authorized to meet electronically please
note that there is no physical location
to observe and listen contemplate
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order and
confirming that we are a providing
public access to the meeting by
telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for the electronic
meeting all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during the meeting through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in the meeting by
clicking on the following website
address
HTTP colon forward slash forward slash
zoom dot US Ford / J 4/9 six to seven
zero four nine one eight three or
dialing one of the following phone
numbers one nine to nine to zero five
six zero nine nine or one three zero one
seven one five eight five nine to
be
in public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting we
previously gave notice to the public of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting including how to access the
meeting using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
see providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting if there are problems with
access
if anybody has a problem please call six
zero three two seven one three six zero
zero or email at HC s @ l EG dot state
NH us d journey the meeting if the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I
want to once again introduce a staff
that are on the meeting assisting us
damn smiling senior House committee
researcher is the meeting host
additional House committee services
staff providing support are practically
Greenland and Gen 4 and Kristina Dyer
this is an exec executive session on
House bill 702 House bill 1710 and House
bill 1712 pursuant to house rule 46 F I
have waived the public hearing on these
bills they work session was held on HB
702 and on February 5th
copies of the bills and how the relevant
materials have been posted on the main
page of a General Court website to the
headache Phoenix please note that all
votes that are taken during the meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
all right let's start the meeting
represent of site tech could take role
one more time and please each member
state their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during the meeting which is required
under the right to know represent aside
those
representatives show it
with no one else in the room
at last I the representative Judy
yet
nobody's next boom
representative Schmidt I
am also present I am alone
representative Schulz president
at home my husband will be in and out of
the ring
representative funk no as in home alone
representative stage
redundant home my sister may be in and
out
be sure to say hello representative
fellows there's no one else in the room
represented it's Fox
[Music]
one more time please present with a
three-year-old
we know representative rodent
president home alone
representative merchant
[Music]
yes present home my wife will be in and
out
representative Pimentel
present home in a rush by myself
representative McGuire
present hello my husband may be in
announce
the clerk is present and by himself
representative Bowden
[Music]
representative proof
Fire Department ELC I'm alone at this
time but I made
lunch
representative Penta City I am home and
representative Pearson I'm in the car
trying to get home by myself
representative Jakob ovitch present home
alone in the room
representative McDonald graduate and
alone
representative goalie
present at home wife maybe in a no okay
a full house
alright
first bill we will take up is House bill
702 in the chair recognizes
representative Schmidt promotion I
will move out to pass on House bill 702
relative to requirements for supervised
visitation centers where it moves House
bill 702 represents do it is there a
second
shoe it
represents MIT would you like to speak
to you motion
I don't have too much to say I just
think this is a appropriate for us to
move forward with
speak to you a second
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay I just I just wanted to state that
we did have the work session on February
5th and during that work session it was
deemed that
as amended this bill
requirements for evna to review this
bill were taken out when it was amended
it was a very brief executive session
brief work session for that fact of
being
recognized represent both Thank You mr.
chairman I probably will support this
bill I don't really have much of a
problem with it but I do want to point
out the Department of Health and Human
Services has stated that the bill is not
expected to have a fiscal impact if you
are to read the safe-haven guidelines
they're quite extensive and in for some
at least some facilities could pose a
substantial fiscal cost and that's
it's going to be filtered down to the
municipalities and agencies that have to
fund those centers so you know I just
have a problem with this repeatedly
happening on bills that we either have
no fiscal impact or it's indeterminate
when in fact they can in fact be very
very substantial that's all I got to say
thank you
thank you further questions or comments
no other hands up represented wire just
put her hand up
McGuire yes thank you mr. chair
my concern besides that of
representative Bowden is that this bill
is completely unenforceable you know
it's a nice statement of intent and we
all want if there are supervised
visitation centers we want them to
follow best principles but this doesn't
have any way for a town to
deal with or
a
center that is found not to be in
compliance and I think that that's
makes the bill totally futile
well intentioned and a nice idea but I'm
I don't think it's going to do any good
represent thank you I just like to point
out in the text of the of the bill that
there's a misspelling that should be
corrected
at least I think it's a misspelling in
line two of the bill or the second line
I don't have a number I'm looking at it
online
talks about the guiding principles so
safe havens I'm sure that should be
spelled pls and PL ES and not PA LS its
use of the word principles in the last
line and it's spelled correctly so one
of the two is wrong I'm sure it's the
first occurrence of the word I tend to
agree with
with the sentiment that has been
expressed that this is
you know
aspirational and
likely is not going to lead to much but
the principles are
quite highly recognized and so forth so
I
would say let's give it a try
any other comments yes representative
SciTech would have a comment
yeah
hi I'm following a representative
Schmidt had said what I was going to but
I want to amplify it a little bit of
course he's right it's ple but I think
that terminology was taken from some
other documents and it was misspelled in
that document and I think enrolled bills
would have put it sick after it but we
can't really change a title from another
document
and I would probably agree because as I
look at Pam's sheet that she gave us it
was also spelt in there and guiding
principles P ALS so I'm thinking that
you are correct represent of scitech
representative I'm sorry
well as I said it's an enrolled bills
kind of thing I think
correct
any other comments representative Stuart
has her hand up
yes I was going to point out the same
thing something that small could be
corrected by enrolled bills but I'm sure
that in the intervening time before this
gets to that point that the source
document can be checked but that's
certainly something that n roll' bills
could correct
Thank You mr. chair so I do have a
comment about
in the last sentence there may be it may
not be enforceable however it does say
that no financial support from a state
or municipal agency can be given to the
divisions visitation center unless it
dump demonstrates those principles
correct
that's what it says
itself is a reason to follow these
guidelines
unless I'm misunderstanding the the
English language here possible
in a fight just to major I mean this
bill is amended took out everything that
had to do with he DNA betting this bill
this was sent to
his committee and
has been voted on the House floor for
that language
for children or family law
[Music]
so the way I see it is there's really no
underlying
information in this bill that P DNA
should be involved with
if there's any other comments we can
take them if not we will go to the roll
I
see no other comments
represent of scitech you may call the
roll motion is ought to passed by
representative Schmitt seconded by
represent of shooing
representative short yeah
representative duty a week
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Fontenot yes
representative Garrett end yes
representative fellows yes
representative Foxx yes
representative Grodin
representative crota yes please
representative merchant yes
representative Pimentel yes
representative Maguire
now
clerk foot yes representative Bowden
representative proof yes
representative City yes
representative pearson yes
representative Jakub ovitch yes
representative Macdonald now
okay 17 3 the chair votes yes I'm sorry
I'm sorry I got you in the
we did good job on the roll call a
final vote
17 to 3 in favor of what the pair's vote
being 17 to 3 the emotion of ought to
pass is adopted
and the next bill will take up
mr. chairman will this be on the consent
calendar any objection to consent
now be in three votes we will won't put
it on consent we'll leave it off consent
and put it on regular calendar
yes represent have McGuire was sense
waiting for that will there be a
minority
I'm not sure if there is I will get it
to you by the end of the day okay thank
you
and the next bill we will take up House
bill 1710
the chair recognizes represent have
grown up for emotion
Thank You mr. chair I move up to pass on
House bill 1710
and representative short means reconcile
second
motion of ought to pass by
representative broad a second by
representative Shu and represent God he
may speak the emotion
Thank You mr. chair I am asking the
committee to support this bill due to
the need for transparency and assistance
with with the
day care eight daycare centers that are
involved in this kind of a process
represent shows like speak to you a
second
yes I will just
echo what representative Cruz stated
that it's currently unfair to have
problems that are found posted until
they have been resolved and I think this
bill goes a long way towards solving
them
any other discussion on hospital 1710 I
don't see any hands mr. chairman
say none
when the clerk is ready the clerk
I'm going to attempt to transition from
my cell phone to my laptop
all right if you could let us call the
roll and then transition in between that
would be great if you could do that I
think I'm in
I'm in you all set I believe I am okay
the motion on hospital 1710 is ought to
pass made by represent wrote a second by
representative Shu it and when ready the
clerk can call roll
representative to it yeah
representative Joo Dee we
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Fontenot yes
representative David end yes
representative fellows yes
representative Fox yes
representative Grodin yes
representative merchants yes
representative Pimentel yes
representative McGuire yes
the clerk 40s representative Bowden yes
represented proof
reluctantly yes because it doesn't go
far enough
representative sannie City yes
representative it Pearson yes
representative Jakob avec
yes
representing McDonald
representing McDonald I
don't point
loading I'm sorry be back I do
Donald can you hear us yes I just got
knocked off I'm sorry okay but your vote
please
yes
and the chair the chair votes yes
42 nothing with the vote of 22 nothing
the motion of octopus is adopted and any
objection to consent
seeing none we'll be on consent and
the last bill we had before is House
bill 1712
represent abroad any other motion
say Thank You mr. chair yes I do I move
out
House bill 1712 PhotoPass
represent sure is that a second a yeah I
second
motion is ought to pass made by
representative broad a second of
everybody that shoe it and represent
Brodie may speak to your motion
thank you this will
rectify some of the issues that are
causing conflicts between daycare
centers and the
agency and
is
giving the daycare centers more time to
respond and to participate in grievances
represent speak to you a second
yes I'll just say that this is basically
a companion to 1710 and I think the two
should go forward
further discussion on House bill 1712
represented McGuire has her hand up
yes thank you this is more of a question
we passed 17 11 which creates a study
committee on the whole process and I'm
not sure why we need this other than as
a
in a one-year stopgap and I'm
curious why we're bothering
my concern going forward with the
waste session is going right now under
the emergency orders is
if that Commission is unable to complete
his work or get together in time to do
the work before next year's filing
deadlines this will be some sort of a
stopgap going forward until they
eventually get the bill through and go
forward and that's one of the reasons
why I'm seeing this going forward is
because the Commission may not be set up
in time to complete its work by the
deadline
and representative Foxx has her hand oh
she took it down I represent a crew has
his hand up represent proof just what
you said we needed something in place
until that committee can do its work
because people are getting mugged
and representative shoo it out
also that at this time we are not sure
how the Senate is going to react to
bills creating studies so I would like
to see this go forward in case they
decide that
studies are impractical or something of
that nature
any other
comments or questions
I see no other hands
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass by represent brought us
seconded by reference to it you see and
when ready the clerk to call the roll
representative shouid know
representative duty we
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz yes
representative no yes
representative date heard end yes
representative fellows yes
representative Fox
did I hear yes yes
yes yes representative Gruden yes
representative merchant yes
represented him tell yes
represented Maguire yes
the clerk votes yes representatives
Bowden yeah
representative proof yes and if you're
still in Epping remind them that that
can be rearranged to spell pigpen
representatives Penna city thank you I
will
represented tena city yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Jakob ovitch yes
representative MacDonald yes and the
chair the chair votes yes a
score to 0 and a vote being
22 noting the motion of water
the motion of octopus is adopted any
objection to consent
seeing none
no 1712 will be on consent I want to
thank everyone for participate and we
had a few technical difficulties getting
started early on in the work session we
got the first housework session
accomplished and I want to thank you for
that we want to thank staff for putting
this together
they helped out a lot and especially on
our first trial and get go on Monday
that was a big help following everyone
together and getting all the members
here and participating today
look forward to seeing you again
probably in the next week and a half or
so maybe whenever we can get the next
exact session in on 1692 we would get
that in the calendar notify everyone and
put that behind us and our committee
work will be done for second committee
bills so it's just about noon time it
looks like it's beautiful out there get
outside enjoy the weather and thank you
and I'll close the executive session